okay well you're all very upstanding
people for staying so late so my name is
Jess humble I work at Google I've been
part of a six year research program into
how to build high-performing technology
organizations run by dr. Niccole force
cringe he's the principal researcher and
we've gathered loads of data over 30,000
data points at this time over six years
and I'm gonna tell you about some of the
results particularly as it pertains to
high-performing teams high-performing
organizations so we've used a bunch of
statistics tools in order to do what we
call predictive analysis so we don't
have causal analysis we don't say one
thing causes another but we can say one
thing predicts another so that's a bit
more than correlations but it's not as
good as causation we can say we're doing
predictive analysis either when we do
randomized controlled experiments which
we don't do it's almost impossible to do
randomized controlled experiments when
you're in the realm of software
I'm just because software teams are
complex systems and it's very difficult
to have you know control group
longitudinal designs experiments where
you're monitoring people over time again
that's very expensive and hard to do we
haven't done that what we're doing is
theory based design where we take
theories that have already been
validated and we use and we create
hypotheses based on those theories and
we test them with data which is what
we've done its survey data that we've
analyzed based on hypotheses which are
based on theories that are already
written about in the literature so when
I talk about something predicting or
impacting something else this is what
I'm talking about and where I'm not
talking what I don't say that I'm
talking about correlations and
correlations are great but correlations
are also misleading there's a great
website called spurious correlations
which has a number of excellent graphs
such as this one white I love Eglin
which correlates per-capita cheese
consumption with a number of people who
died by becoming tangled in their bed
sheets and there's lots more like that
so correlations are interesting but they
don't tell you whether one thing causes
another whether there's a third hidden
variable that's causing those two things
or whether in fact they have no causal
relationship whatsoever so with that
note of warning I'll carry on what we
found over the last six years first of
all is that software delivery is a
competitive advantage and if you saw me
speak this morning there'll be about
five minutes worth of overlap for this
morning's talk I apologize for that but
then we'll move on to completely new
terrain that we haven't covered so firms
with high performing software delivery
capabilities were twice as likely to
exceed their profitability market share
and productivity goals so software
delivery is important it impacts
commercial goals it also impacts
non-commercial goals that nonprofits and
government and everyone else has so high
performers have more than twice as
likely to also exceed objectives related
to customer satisfaction the quality of
products or service provided the ability
to achieve organization and mission
goals and a bunch of other things that
organizations care about so software
delivery matters how do we measure
software delivery we found four valid
and reliable measures that allow you to
measure software delivery performance
and they're the four colored ones and
I'll talk about availability in just a
minute so lead time is the time from
checking code in to version control to
having software in production deployment
frequency is how frequently you deploy
to production those are two measures of
throughput or speed or tempo then in
blue we have measures of reliability
chains fail rate when you push a change
out what percentage of the time do you
have to remediate in some way because
something went wrong time to restore
when something does go wrong when
there's an incident of some kind how
long does it take you to fix that and
restore service
and then I mean those four metrics apply
to everything they you can apply them to
apps to firmware to you know anything
that software related last year we also
looked at availability which only really
make sense for hosted stuff and in that
situation availability works like the
other ones and works like the other ones
means this and this is the crucial fact
what we find is that high performers are
doing really well at all of these things
there's this kind of very common
misconception that people trade-off
speed against stability and availability
and we find that's not the case we've
reproduced these results for the last
six years and what we find is that when
we do cluster analysis on our data
it always splits up into three or four
groups where there's a group that's
doing really well in this case in a
league group that's able to deploy
on-demand multiple times per day lead
time for changes of less than a day time
crystal service of less than an hour and
a really low change fail rate and then
in the other ends there's a lie
performing group and and exactly how
well they're performing varies year to
year but 2019 we find they're deploying
between once a month and once every six
months their lead time for changes is
between once a month and six months or
sorry between one month and six months
because they're releasing code in big
batches they're doing you know big batch
releases but time to restore service is
really shockingly worrying and we think
what's happening there is that
particularly in the case of security
incidents security breaches it takes a
really long time to fix everything even
if you can kind of get the system back
up and running you've got data fixes on
the back end and stuff like that and
then this high change fail rate so we've
consistently found there's an elite
performing group there's a low
performing group and then there's one or
two groups in the middle who are doing
better than the low performers but not
as well as the elite performers this is
true across all different sizes of
companies he finds high performers in
big companies of 10,000 or more
and you find low performance in small
companies I've certainly worked or have
friends let's say who've worked at
startups which would be in the life
forming group and I've worked in teams
and the US federal government but were
high-performing groups we also find that
these results generalize across industry
you find high performers in highly
regulated organizations including
financial services telecoms government
health care and you can find low
performing groups in in technology so
you don't have to be a small technology
startup to be a high performer you can
be in a big highly regulated
organization and be a high performer and
equally you can be in a small start-up
and be a low performer too
so obviously you want to know how to get
better we've been looking at that too
and what we find is there's a load of
stuff which predicts software delivery
performance this is what we lovingly
call the the BFD the big and fulsome
diagram these are all the things that
predict software a livery performance so
I talked about some of these things this
morning particularly around cloud
infrastructure this afternoon I'm going
to talk about a bunch of the rest of
them and there's four basic categories
that I want to cover firstly I want to
talk a little bit about continuous
delivery and technical practices then
I'm going to talk about lean management
and product development practices I'm
going to spend a bunch of time talking
about culture and then autonomous teams
are the fourth ingredient so all four of
these things predicts software delivery
performance so if you want to get better
the way you do it is by implementing
these groups of capabilities so let's
start with the technical practices
continuous delivery so continuous
delivery basically is about making
releases boring making production
deployments things you can do at any
time of day at the push of a button
the more formal definition is that you
can make any kind of changes in safely
and quickly and sustainably whether
that's data based changes or network
changes or software changes you know
whatever it is infrastructure changes
that should be a low-risk predictable
process who in this room has to perform
deployments evenings and weekends okay
like around twenty five percent of you
so I'm gonna take that as a sign of
personal failure that we write the
continuous delivery book nine years ago
basically so that people didn't have to
deploy software at evenings and weekends
anymore that that was the goal to make
sure that you could do deployments at
any time and it was a boring process
we're still not there yet I'm sorry
that's that's not the case but I think
it's important not to accept that as an
inevitable consequence of the software
delivery process I've been working in
all kinds of organizations and gathering
case studies and we've shown that you
can achieve continuous delivery in the
federal government building firmware
building apps highly complex distributed
systems there's no I mean it's hard it's
really hard but it's not impossible
and you can get there incrementally and
iteratively so don't lose hope it's
entirely possible to do it it does
require a whole bunch of stuff to be
implemented and that's what I'm talking
about today so over the years we've
discovered a whole bunch of technical
practices which predict your ability to
do continuous delivery from source
control practices like checking
everything including infrastructure
configuration into version control which
we used to call infrastructure as code
and we now call get UPS continuous
integration trunk base development
instead of working on long live feature
branches to things like architecture
building a loosely coupled architecture
test practices such as continuous
testing which means testing throughout
the software delivery lifecycle rather
than in phases
automation database change management
this year we found something new called
code maintainability which I'll talk
about in just a minute we find these
practices not only improve performance
they also reduce team burnout reduce
deployment pain and increase quality as
measured by the percentage of your time
you're working on features as opposed to
unplanned work or other kind of rework
caused by things that you didn't do
right the first time so continuous
delivery doesn't just make you better a
software delivery it makes your teams
happier and it improves your quality as
well it also impacts culture which is
something I'll come back to you later
so in the state of DevOps reports we
talked about these things in some depth
I just wanna talk about Co
maintainability cuz it's a new thing
that we looked at this year when you
have systems and tools that make it easy
to change code maintained by other teams
to find code in the codebase to read
other people's code and to add upgrade
and migrates and new versions of
dependencies that is one capability that
we know predicts your ability to achieve
continuous delivery and all these
capabilities have been written up if you
go to cloud google.com slash DevOps
dorra when we were required by Google
basically stole that domain and put all
our stuff on it so you can go to cloud
or Google or common DevOps and read
about each of these capabilities in
detail fundamentally what continuous
delivery is about is building quality in
making sure that you actually make sure
that the things that you care about in
your software are built in by developers
rather than trying to fix those problems
later and this goes back to the early
days of lean Demings 14 points which you
wrote about decades ago such as this one
and really the point is you know if you
want security and then people have
talked about this even today if you want
security if you want scalability if you
want reliability you can't wave their
magic DevOps wand and have the DevOps
unicorns come and give that to you after
dev complete that doesn't work
developers have to
that into the system from the beginning
which means the developers have to
understand that and know about it and we
have to help developers do that right in
the first place it's very expensive
or I'm almost impossible to try and fix
these things later on and really a lot
of continuous delivery is about building
feedback loops into our software
delivery process to make it possible to
do this it's not the developers are dumb
or that they're evil it's that they just
don't have the feedback loops that
enable them to do this stuff in the
first place so those are the technical
practices we also found a set of lean
management and product development
practices so the management proscape
abilities are things like limiting work
in process having visual management
things like displays that show you how
many automated tests are failing things
like that feedback from production and
using that feedback to make business
decisions and a light weight change
approval process and what's interesting
is when we actually went and looked at
the data we thought that limiting
working process would predict software
delivery performance on its own and we
found that it didn't that was really
weird it's you know slam dunk everyone
who studies lean knows that limiting
work in process makes things better but
when we actually ran that analysis on
the data we found that that wasn't the
case what we found is you have to
combine limiting work in process with
visual management and feedback from
production in order to have the impact
on software delivery performance so as
we do our analysis we find all these
interesting things sometimes our
assumptions are wrong and our hypotheses
that disproves and we need to go and do
further analysis so that's only kind of
interesting tip bits that came out of
this research program is that you've got
to combine some of these things to see
the impact lightweight change approvals
is something that gets a lot of pushback
what this is is when you make a change
who works at a company where before you
can take software changes and push them
live the release has to be
moved by a change Advisory Board or some
other team that's external to the
software team who has that situation
about 25% of you okay so in the course
of our research program we found that
that doesn't work what it does is it
release it reduces throughput and does
nothing to improve stability so
basically it slows you down without
giving you any corresponding benefit and
we did a deep dive on that this year so
if you go and download the 2019 Stata
devops report there's a whole section on
why that kind of heavyweight changed
approval process doesn't in fact work
what does work is when you have a
lightweight change approval process
which means code review within your team
or pair programming or other mechanisms
by which people on the team check each
other's code so it's not that change
approval is bad it's that it has to be
done you know in in small batches pretty
soon after the code is written by people
on your team who actually understand
what's going on and you can absolutely
achieve the goals of control objectives
like segregation of duties that we
absolutely care about in regulated
organizations using a lightweight
process that's very effective but heavy
weight change approval doesn't actually
work even though it's not I mean it's
basically not the best way to achieve
that control objective lean product
development a reset of practices that
come from I mean they've been talked
about a lot in the Lean Startup
literature that's things like working in
small batches where we define that as
being able to complete work in a few
days or less than a week so when you
build a new features you should be able
to complete them and get them out in a
few days making the flow of work visible
that's everyone in the organization
being able to see work as it flows from
idea to being developed to all the
various stages it needs to go to to get
its production gathering an implementing
customer feedback and then one of my
favorite ones team experimentation so
it's
team experimentation means that the
people working on the software have to
be able to change requirements in
response to what they learn and what
they know about the system who here
works in an organization that's agile or
a team that's agile I mean everyone
right because everyone says they're
agile right and you know I'm working a
team that's like waterfall we are doing
waterfall okay a couple of me so you
know who works in an agile team where
the developers you know you have to do
what's written on the story cards and
you don't get any input into that okay a
few of you are like yes so yeah I mean
that that's the real thing you know yeah
we're using story cards we're having
stand-ups everyone's been to the two
days scrum training and now we're taking
orders from management standing up
instead of sitting down and that big
backlog of requirements you can't ever
complete is now prioritize and estimated
in we're agile yeah but you still you
know why why are we doing this just do
what's written on the cart okay I'll
take the story cards over here and so it
turns out that's not agile it's only
agile if you get to actually have a
conversation and discuss what's being
done and as developers you get to
experiment with ideas and you get to
experiment with process change as well
process change should be something that
teams have the authority to experiment
with when you know management sits down
and says you will follow this recipe to
implement agile and there should be no
deviations you know guess what that's
not that trial so we found that team
experimentation a impact software
delivery performance it drive software
delivery performance along with those
other capabilities in the lean product
development box it also drives culture
both of these things drive culture and
software delivery performance also
drives lean product development
there's virtuous circle they're mutually
reinforcing better software delivery
performance enables more lean product
development because if you can delay
faster and more reliably you can test
ideas more quickly and get feedback more
quickly that enables you to work in
small batches which in turn drives
software delivery performance so those
two things lean product development
software delivery performance in
mutually reinforcing and lean product
development directly drives
organizational performance so again
another interesting thing about this is
you can see what drives what if you want
to directly drive organizational
performance you need to implement these
lean product development practices those
will also drive software livery
performance so seeing which way the
arrows point and what they point to is a
good way to reason back from the
outcomes you want to achieve to the
things that you can implement that will
drive those outcomes and that's why the
BFD is so cool so I've talked about
culture that culture has popped up in
this box quite a lot I want to talk a
bit about culture and and what I mean
when I talk about culture so culture
drives software livery performance
culture also drives organizational
performance what do we mean by culture
there are many models of culture the
model of culture that we studied comes
from a sociologist called ron westrom
and westrom was studying safety outcomes
in healthcare aviation and nuclear power
so these are domains where when things
go wrong people die say safety critical
domains how do we build effective safety
cultures and he came up with this
typology which divides organizations up
into pathological or power oriented
bureaucratic or rule oriented and then
generative or performance oriented or or
mission oriented is a number another way
to think about that and there are six
axes on this model do people cooperate
with each other really well is there
high cooperation or low cooperation how
do we handle bad news do we train people
to bring us bad knees so that we can act
on it quickly before problems become
catastrophic do we ignore people who
bring us bad
or do we shoot the messenger our
responsibilities avoided because I know
that if I take on a responsibility and
so on something goes wrong I'll be fired
the responsibilities define narrowly so
that when something goes wrong we know
whose fault it is and we can punish them
or are risks shed because we know that
we succeed and fail as a team is
bridging between departments and between
different parts of the organization
encouraged or tolerated or discouraged
so an example of this is you know you go
into the soft dark I get called in
sometimes to companies to help them and
I'm like hey can we talk to the product
people and they're like no he can talk
to the product people okay
why not are they in a different building
oh no they're on the next floor down we
just don't want them to know that we're
talking about this continuous delivery
thing because then they'll try to shut
it all down so that's an example of when
bridging is discouraged right because we
don't trust each other and when we don't
trust each other information doesn't
flow through the organization
effectively and then two things that are
really two sides of the same coin how do
we deal with failure and how do we deal
with novelty so in an organization where
failure leads to scapegoating you know
this thing went wrong
it was jezus fault let's fire jazz
verses this thing went wrong yes
jazz did this thing which we can see led
to this outcome why did jazz do this
thing well how could we have got jazz
better information so that he didn't
make that decision how could we have
given jazz better tools so that when
what am I talking about myself in the
third person is so weird when Jose did
this thing
it caused this thing with the tool
caught it so it didn't lead to
catastrophic or cascading failure we are
all working in complex systems and in
complex systems there's this temporal
asymmetry when you look back after an
accident it's easy to look up the causal
chain of what happened and trace it back
to someone but when you're doing stuff
and looking forward it's really hard
often to predict that this thing you do
would trigger that thing
which was related to this other thing up
here that I didn't even know about and
that leads to a weird series of
cascading failures that I couldn't have
predicted looking back it's really easy
to see how it happened but when I'm
sitting here doing my thing you know
it's how would I know that that happened
in complex systems failure is inevitable
in complex systems failure is inevitable
you will there will be failure and the
interesting question is not why this
person did this thing but how can we
improve the system and get that person
better information and better tools to
prevent that happening again because if
we fire that person what's going to
happen we're going to replace them with
someone else and the same thing is going
to happen to that person unless we
actually work to improve the system so
in organizations or teams where failure
leads to scapegoating nobody's going to
try anything new because novelty doing
things that hasn't haven't been done
before have a high risk of failure than
things we've already tried and we know
that failure leads to scapegoating and
so we're never going to try anything new
so if you want your team to try new
things you have to create an environment
where failure isn't punished and that
sounds obvious but it's really really
hot Google has a whole team that looks
at developer productivity and how to
build effective teams they ran this
quite well-known study that I'm sure a
lot of you know about called project
Aristotle where they looked at how to
build effective teams at Google and they
thought it would be you know hire a
bunch of Stanford graduates fire all the
managers and you know put all the PhDs
in charge what they found actually was
that the most important factor in
building effective teams was
psychological safety did team members
feel safe to take risks and be
vulnerable in front of each other that
was actually the biggest factor and what
we found we actually asked about
psychological safety and these other
five things on a survey that we did a
few years ago along with westrom
questions and what we found is that
these things here are the same as the
first two things on this list so we
replicate is part of Google's results as
part of our research program it's always
really nice when you can reproduce
someone else's results in to study it
kind of gives it a lot more power so we
were able to reproduce his result so we
know that this culture a high trust
generative performance mission oriented
culture directly drives software
delivery performance it drives those
organisational outcomes how do you
change your culture well the way you
change your culture is by implementing
those capabilities that we talked about
the technical capabilities continuous
delivery the products management and
lean management capabilities
implementing those capabilities is what
drives culture so if you want to change
your culture you change how your teams
do their work and that in turn as the
BFD shows is driven by transformational
leadership so again the way that these
kind of boxes and arrows are arranged is
important having transformational
leadership enables you to implement the
practices and capabilities implementing
those capabilities drives software
delivery performance directly and it
also changes your culture and a more
performance oriented culture in turn
drive software delivery performance so
what does a high trust culture look like
that's a company called Etsy which in
the USA provides a storefront for people
making their own crafts and until a
couple of years ago when there was a
huge management change driven by the
investors it was one of the companies
that was a great example an exemplar of
DevOps practices they had an annual
developer conference another developer
conference they gave out an award to the
engineer who'd caused the biggest
production outage in the last year this
was the three armed sweater award
because if you enter Etsy calm and got a
404 there was a picture of her sweater
with three arms so the three on sweater
award went to the engineer who caused
the biggest outage
and this was not ironic or sarcastic it
was it was genuine it thank you for
finding this problem so that we were
able to fix it and improve our system
and get better or what you do here's a
theory on sweater thank you very much so
you can actually this is John old sport
on the left and Rin daniels on the right
and you can actually go and read R in
Daniels blog post where they talk about
the problem and what happens and how
they dealt with it it's a really
interesting read I I very much recommend
that going and looking at that and one
of the things that Rin says is that when
they spotted this outage the immediate
response from everyone around was to ask
what helped you need and they swarmed on
the problem and fixed it and then they
had a blameless postmortem and found
ways to improve the system so that
couldn't happen again and then Rin gets
the three on sweater rewards at yeah
Neil Developer Conference so that's what
high performance culture looks like and
it actually goes beyond that in high
performance culture we're always trying
to create problems so that we can find
ways to improve the system because we
know it's by creating problems that we
discover ways to improve the system so
Google has a disaster recovery testing
exercise a dirt exercise we call it
every year where there's a whole team
that actually plans out scenarios like
aliens invade Silicon Valley and they do
things like switching off connections
between data centers all kinds of kind
of unusual and unexpected things and the
engineers have to keep the systems up
and running through that exercise it's a
really big deal it was run for a long
time by Kripa Krishnan she says for
dirts style events to be successful an
organization first needs to accept
system and process failures as a means
of learning we design tests that require
engineers from several groups who might
not normally work together to interact
with each other that way should a real
large-scale disaster ever strike these
people will already have strong working
relationships so if you want to get if
you want to be be comfortable about the
possibility of failure the best way to
do that is to practice it and it's by
practicing it
you'll discover how to improve your
system and get better and then as a
bonus when something bad does happen
you're like oh yeah I know what to do I
know who's on call I know the different
systems I've got to look at to find out
what's gone wrong I know who's in charge
of those systems and you're comfortable
with it because you practiced it loads
of times this year we looked at disaster
recovery testing we asked about it
explicitly we found that only 40% of
organizations perform disaster recovery
testing at least annually on production
infrastructure that's a huge problem
that's something everyone should be
doing is practicing disaster recovery at
least annually on their production
infrastructure if not more often so with
that in mind some other things that
directly impact culture retrospectives
post-mortems blameless post-mortems
learning exercises those directly impact
culture they also create a climate for
learning in which learning is seen as a
strategic investment rather than
something that people should do in their
own time and a culture a climate for
learning also drives culture directly
finally I want to talk about autonomous
teams last year we found that when you
outsource functions like testing and
operations to other organizations that
drives down software delivery
performance functional outsourcing is
bad it reduces speed and stability we
talked about change process earlier one
of the big things you can do when you're
growing autonomous teams is build is
build trust and give people the ability
to speak up and giving teams autonomy is
one thing that does that so giving teams
autonomy drives software delivery
performance directly it also makes
people trust each other more that makes
them feel more able to speak up those
things directly impact culture and
culture drive software livery
performance and operational performance
what does that look like in practice I
still really like this presentation from
Reed Hastings of C of Netflix where he
talks about
Netflix culture and there's this slide
that I particularly like where he talks
about highly aligned loosely coupled
teams and this is an architectural thing
one of the things we talked about in
state of divorces is a loosely coupled
architecture but it's also an
organizational thing and Conway's law
says that those two things the systems
architecture and the organizational
architecture support each other
what you want is teams that are highly
aligned to where they have a clear
common strategy and set of goals that
are known to everyone and that everyone
is working towards and that team
interactions are focused on those those
strategic things rather than individual
tactics but then you want teams to be
loosely coupled so you don't want them
to be meeting all the time because
there's these fine-grained dependencies
between the work they do which again
requires cross-functional teams where
everyone involved in design delivery
operations co-located that's what
enables you to have fine-grain
interactions happen within the team and
coarse-grain interactions between teams
and then post mortems on tactics in
order to increase alignment and then
crucially trust between those different
groups so for things we've covered how
do you improve software delivery
performance these things continuous
delivery lean management and product
development a mission oriented culture
with psychological safety and autonomous
cross-functional teams if you're the
only really sustainable way to do this
is to have leadership support
transformational leadership is the only
way to ensure that when you try these
things out they become institutionalized
but if you don't have that you should
still go ahead and try things out
gorilla change management is better than
no change management so I want to end
with these words from Rear Admiral Grace
Hopper there's a good idea go ahead
do it it's much easier to apologize than
it is to get permission thanks very much
we have five minutes for questions
thankee all right all the stuff is on
cloud or google.com slash DevOps yes
yeah
yes so what do you do when you don't
have transformational transformational
leadership so I wouldn't say it's a
prerequisite I say that it helps it
definitely drives those things I think
the important thing to remember about
leadership is that leadership doesn't
mean the executives anyone can be a
leader a leader is about taking
ownership of things and rewarding people
and supporting people and providing
stimulation and inspiring people anyone
can do that
so anyone can be a leader and I've
certainly seen in big organizations
you'll have teams where you've got a
courageous manager who will kind of help
teams experiment and then pretend to the
rest of the organization that
everything's fine nothing to see here
right so I mean every big organization
I've worked in certainly your experience
as an employee is very much driven by
who you reporting rather than the
organization as a whole if you're
working for someone who's is a good
manager and knows how to help you and
help you grow and help the team work
together effectively even if the rest of
the organization is kind of a bit of a
trash fire that can be a really good
experience equally if you're working in
like a good organization but your
managers awful that can be really really
miserable so I think a big piece of this
is you know just working for a good
having reporting to someone who's a good
manager so I mean obviously there's no
way to control that until you get into
the organization once you know in the
organization then you can find those
people and try and work with them I mean
there's also martin fowler's advice
which is change your company or change
your company but obviously that depends
on there being jobs available for you to
go into as well so that's the very end
of the end of the rope advice I think
but I would say you know it's every
organization is very every big
organization is very heterogeneous
people ask me like which are the great
organizations and
you know that they are all very
different inside you know I can tell you
that Google there's some things that are
great about Google there's some things
that are not so great about Google and
there's some things about working in the
federal government but I'd really really
loved so it's just about where you are
in the organization and your local
experience I think is a much bigger deal
than the overall organization other
questions is there free beer or
something outside
all right well let me here for a few
minutes thanks very much for your time
have a great evening
[Applause]